お話の中でサンニャーというライルの塊で勉強するのも経験するのもサンニャーを増やしているということでおっしゃってたと思うんですが
私が時々自分で暴れなくなることは
仏教の勉強をしてて その勉強しているがゆえにそれを理解できなくて苦しんだりとか
頭ではわかってるんだけど
経験として実感できないとかっていう苦しみというか
もどかしさみたいなものもあるんですけれども
それはやっぱりそのドゥッカとは違うんですか？ まあそれもあのサンニャー自体ははっきり整理整頓してくれないっていうことだから
自分でははっきり整理整頓したいという欲が生まれてくると
ドゥッカになるんです
ドゥッカっていうこと自体には変わりがないんですか？例えば
勉強してない人のドゥッカ
私がいるという思っているドゥッカと
勉強してもやっぱり私がいると思っている
まだドゥッカがある そのドゥッカは違うんですか？ それは人によりますから
勉強したからものすごい苦しむこともあり得るし
よくあることは 例えば仏教では業とか話があるでしょ
いいことをしたらいいことになるんだそうと
そういう人々なんか それは頭の知識だけ
そう サンニャーだけなんですよ
それ 自分が悪いことをしないんですね
なのに自分がもう会社をクビになるとか
子供がとんでもない突然すごい病気になって死んでしまったとかいうことで
ものすごい苦しむんですよ
なんでや これと 私は何の悪いことをしていないのに
なんでクビになったんでしょうかとか
さらに苦しむ で なんでいいことをしているのにとかね
なんで私はいいことをしているのに
子供はこうになったんでしょうかとか
その場合は勉強したものを結局は自分の苦しみを増やしてくれる
それで使い方次第 またもう一人の人が
まあ物事っていうのはそんなもんで
因果法則ですから まあしょうがないっていう風に思っちゃえば苦しみが減るんですよ
だから勉強したものがどう使うかという
またそちらにも自分のサンニャーが働くんです
だから何も知らない人はそれなりに苦しみが低いところもあるし
例えば自分ががんにかかっているのにがんであると知らないで
何の何のことなく死んでしまうとかね
ガンだよと言われたところでもうサンニャーが入ったでしょ
これですっごい余計な苦しみが生まれてくる
肉体の苦しみはそれで同じですけど
余計な精神的な苦しみが入り込んじゃって
肉体の苦しみも増やしちゃう場合もあります
あるいは ある知識の人がしっかりとがんですかと
はい わかりましたと言って理解しておけば
普通の人よりも楽しく穏やかで
もうあと何日でしょうかと考えて生きていられることもできる
だから人のアプローチ次第ですね
アプローチも一つのサンニャーなんです
ありがとうございました
はい  他にごいますでしょうか
どちらさき じゃあ後ろの方が先
サンカラについてなんです
サンカラ はい 業ですね
はい 一度生じると結果が出るまでたまらない
うん おっしゃいました
大先生もです それもその例えば修行とかで消すことはできます
できます できます うん
特にヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
このサンカーラの働きはその場でその場でもうコテンパテンと消すんです
修行では他の他の修行でも大体消しますよ
消えていく いわゆる消えると言ったっても
エネルギーはなんて言いますかね
はこのニュートラル状態に
例えば戒律を守るとかね
嘘を言わないようにすると
もうかなり頑張らないと
自分がね 少し嘘を言いやすいでしょ
それで私は嘘をつかんそうと決める
決めちゃうと 怒りから欲から出てくるあのサンカーラがもうどうも機能できんだから
もう抑えられてるんだから
もう結構弱くなるんです
で 何でも無常やとはっきりと瞑想でもって体験しちゃうと
もう全部エネルギーはそれでたちまち消えるんです
はい 前 はい  心にエネルギーを入れていけば
体からことが離れる うん
それをもっと強くすると体の方が消えてしまう
消えるっていうのはこの世では起こりませんよ
で 例えば強烈なエネルギー
それ集中力ですけどね
だからあれあれ 糸を巻くような感じで
同じ中心点があって回さなくちゃいけないんですよ
何か瞑想体位をとって
そこにずっと集中しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそのやり方で 瞑想している場合は体の実感がなくなるんですね
だから体があるということ
体を認識することだから
体を認識しないと 足もお腹も背中も頭も何も認識しないと本人にはもう消えているんです
見ないものはないようになるでしょ？聞いてない音はもうないことになるでしょ
そういう感じで体がないことになるんです
しかし また瞑想をやめたら
また体に意識が戻って体があるんじゃないかということになるんです
その瞑想とヴィパッサナーは全然別のもの
ヴィパッサナーは直接に
無我を発見して悟ろうと
これはもうすごい早道なんです
あれではもう ただもうそういうことかっていうことで終わっちゃうんです
では そろそろ 5時半になりましたので
最後の回をしたいと思います
向こうの三宝に礼拝致し
感謝を込めて慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖先 親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに奉仕いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして平安が得られますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィワジャンツー サッバローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワットアンタラーヨー スキーディーガ
ー ユコー バワー バホトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブンダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダン
マヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティバワントゥ テ アビワダナシーリッサー ニッチャンワッダパチャイノー
チャッターロー ダンマワッダンティー アユワンノー スカンバラン
そういうことで どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます